bonjour à tous
bonjour à tous merci merci à tous je
suis très heureux d'être avec vous une
nouvelle fois guidel cette année ça
faisait un bon moment qu'on s'était pas
retrouvé tous ensemble et je crois que
c'est toujours ces moments de familles
qui sont extrêmement importants je suis
très content également parce que cette
année nous avons décidé le le modem a
décidé d'organiser
son événement sur sa première journée
sur le développement durable et je crois
que c'est un signe important on traverse
aujourd'hui dans le monde de nombreuses
ruptures des ruptures qui sont
économiques technologiques sociales est
également et nous le savons tous
environnementale l'environnement est un
sujet qui est devenu le vecteur numéro 1
des implications et des inquiétudes des
citoyens et c'est pourquoi nous devons
absolument répondre à cette
problématique
comme nous le savons par rapport à
l'urgence climatique
donc j'accueille avec moi pour une
première séquence valérie
masson-delmotte que vous connaissez sans
doute qui est
paléoclimatologue spécialiste du
réchauffement climatique sur la
modélisation des climats du passé pour
se rendre compte de ce que l'équipe
climat futur vont être alors valérie
elle a un parcours qui est exceptionnel
depuis 2008 elle est directrice de
recherche au commissariat à l'énergie
atomique elle est également coprésidente
du groupe numéro un du giec depuis 2015
qui est le groupe qui étudie tous les
aspects scientifiques
sur cette question c'est quelqu'un qui
est reconnue écouter sur la scène
internationale et qui a toujours profité
de son aura pour pouvoir vulgariser la
question du climat pour pouvoir défendre
la problématique qui existe aujourd'hui
elle n'a pas hésité également à
s'engager sur des positions liées à
l'urgence climatique
alors on se rappelle de l'appel qu'elle
a pu cosigné demandant la fin de
l'extraction des énergies fossiles
également en 2018 lors de la crise de
gilet jaune elles signent un appel pour
appeler à une délibération citoyen nes
aboutira sur la convention citoyenne
pour le climat elle questionne
notre modèle économique et notamment la
publicité qui dans un esprit de sobriété
interroge sur est-ce que la tentation
d'un côté la sobriété de l'autre peuvent
exister de façon tout à fait harmonieuse
et enfin elle demande l appelle les
autorités publiques à s'engager pour le
pour adapter notre société contre le
réchauffement climatique et surtout pour
prendre en compte la difficulté des plus
faibles dans cette danse est
problématique bonjour bonjour valérie
bonjour donc valérie avec nous en
visioconférence aujourd'hui valérie moi
je vous propose peut-être de nous
exprimer un petit peu les résultats du
dernier rapport du giec il ya eu pas mal
de conclusion et vous avez beaucoup
travaillé sur le sujet oui merci
infiniment de cette occasion de vous
présenter l'état des lieux scientifique
vis-à-vis de ce climat qui change et
avec lequel nous vivons je précise que
un rapport du giec c'est rédigé par 234
scientifique de 65 pays dont 12
climatologues brillant français des
centaines de contributeurs
des milliers de relecteur et c'est
l'examen critique des éléments de
connaissance de plus de 14000
publications scientifiques qui étaye ses
quelques conclusions que je vais vous
résumer et donc l'état des lieux
s'appuie sur les progrès issus des
observations de la compréhension des
processus de la modélisation du climat
global et régional de l'étude des
climats passés et nous avons donc une
connaissance de plus en plus précise du
fonctionnement du climat de la terre de
l' influence humaine sur celui-ci et des
évolutions futures en réponse au choix
que nous pouvons faire nous savons mieux
que jamais comment le climat évalué dans
le pas évolué dans le passé comment ils
changent actuellement et comment il peut
lui et à l'avenir alors d'abord nous en
sommes nous aujourd'hui il est clair que
les activités humaines sont à l'origine
du changement climatique en cours notre
meilleure estimation c'est que la
totalité du réchauffement nous en sommes
à 1,1 degré sur les derniers dix ans par
rapport à la fin du 19e siècle donc la
totalité de ce réchauffement est due aux
conséquences des émissions issues des
activités humaines
le réchauffement dû à l'effet de serre
en particulier le dioxyde de carbone le
méthane et d'autres gaz à effet de serre
étant partiellement masquée par le
refroidissement due aux particules de
pollution
les changements climatiques récents sont
généralisés rapide et s'intensifie ils
sont sans précédent depuis des milliers
d'années c'est vraiment une situation de
rupture
l'élévation du niveau des mers qui est
importante pour le littoral en métropole
dans les outre-mers
s'accélère ça a monté de 20 cm au cours
du 20e siècle ça monte aujourd'hui au
rythme de 3,7 mm chaque année parce que
au gonflement de l'océan qui se
réchauffe à la fonte des glaciers
s'ajoute une perte croissante du
groenland et de l'antarctique
et puis le changement climatique
d'origine humaine affecte chaque région
de la terre en europe et ailleurs de
multiples façons des tendances ans mais
aussi des extrêmes qui sont plus
fréquents plus intenses en particulier
les vagues de chaleur les épisodes de
fortes précipitations les sécheresses
tout particulièrement autour de la
méditerranée et puis aussi les
conditions météorologiques chaudes et
sèches propice aux incendies et on l'a
vu cet été alors quelles sont les
évolutions futures possibles ce qui est
important à comprendre c'est que chaque
fraction de réchauffement supplémentaire
contre et les changements que nous
subissons partout s'accentueront avec la
poursuite du réchauffement
nous avons scientifiquement fortement
réduit notre plage d'incertitude associé
à la réponse du climat aux émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à venir alors la
première chose importante c'est que si
on mettait tout à zéro demain duré
quasiment pas plus de réchauffement ce
qui va se passer à l'avenir ça dépend
pas des émissions passées
nous avons une responsabilité historique
bien sûr mais l'évolution de la
température à venir va dépendre des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
venir
néanmoins il ya une inertie une inertie
dans nos infrastructures dans les
véhicules qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui
dans les systèmes de chauffage dans les
usines les centrales thermiques qui
existe aujourd'hui et donc dans tous les
scénarios d'émissions que l'on envisage
même en cas de forte baisse d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre on continuera à
avoir des émissions mais décroissante
année après année et donc dans tous les
cas la température à la surface du globe
elle va continuer à augmenter au moins
quelques décennies
nous évaluons qu'un niveau de
réchauffement planétaire d'environ un
degré et demi l'une des aspirations de
l'accord de paris sur le climat contenir
le réchauffement à un niveau aussi bas
mais ce niveau là sera atteint au cours
des prochains 20 ans en moyenne sur une
vingtaine d'années et à moins de réduire
vraiment considérablement les rejets de
gaz à effet de serre et en particulier
dioxyde de carbone dans les années à
venir dans les décennies à venir ce
niveau sera ensuite dépasser si on prend
les promesses faites par les états en
2015 au moment de la signature de
l'accord de paris sur le climat et leur
réactualisation la semaine dernière ses
promesses impliquant fait une stagnation
dans le meilleur des cas des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre entre maintenant
et 2030 c'est à dire si toutes ces
promesses se réalise pleinement si les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre stagne
au niveau actuel quelques décennies
alors on va dépasser en degré et demi et
puis 2 degrés autour du milieu de ce
siècle et si ces promesses implique une
stagnation et pas davantage on s'attend
à un réchauffement de l'ordre de deux à
trois et demi degré à la fin de ce
siècle selon les connaissances actuelles
donc j'ai précisé un de nombreux
changements simplifiant en relation
directe avec le niveau de réchauffement
climatique c'est le cas de
l'augmentation de la fréquence et de
l'intensité des vagues de chaleur sur
terre comme en mer des fortes
précipitations des sécheresses en
particulier autour de la méditerranée de
la proportion des cyclones tropicaux les
plus intenses mais aussi du recul de la
glace de mer près du pôle nord de
l'enneigement en moyenne montagne auprès
des pôles et puis du dégel des le jeu
les prés de l'arctique ou en montagne
nous avons des choses beaucoup plus fine
sur le lien entre climat et aux un
climat plus chaud intensifie le cycle de
l'eau et sa variabilité une atmosphère
plus chaude peut contenir 7% de plus de
vapeur d'eau mais une atmosphère plus
chaude elle favorise l'évaporation la
transpiration des sols elle vide plus
vite les sols de leur humidité avec un
climat qui se réchauffe ans on s'attend
à des événements et des saisons
climatiques très humide ou très sèche
plus variable et donc des répercussions
aussi sur la gestion de l'eau les ide au
risque d'inondation ou de sécheresse
il est important de comprendre aussi que
de nombreux changements liés aux
émissions passées et futures de gaz à
effet de serre sont irréversibles donc
déjà on peut pas revenir en arrière et
puis l'océan profond va continuer à
s'ajuster pendant des siècles le
groenland l'antarctique vont continuer à
s'ajuster à des échelles de siècle et de
milliers d'années la montée du niveau
des mers et les irréversible elle va se
poursuivre le niveau des mers va
continuer à s'élever mais le rythme
l'amplitude de cette élévation au fil
des siècles dépend profondément de ce
qu'on va faire en termes d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en cas de forte
diminution ça pourrait être 50
centimètres de plus en 2100 par rapport
à 1990 en cas de forte hausse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
pourrait être de l'ordre du mètre à la
fin de ce siècle mais dans tous les cas
ce sera plusieurs mètres sur les siècles
suivants
plus on agit plus on limite la vitesse
de montée du niveau des mers plus cela
laisse le temps pour l'adaptation sur
l'ensemble des littoraux mondiaux où
vivront en 2050 plus d'un milliard de
personnes et puis les événements
extrêmes liés au niveau de la mer quand
vous avez une marée haute et une forte
tempête en plus de cette hausse
graduelle ils vont se produire de plus
en plus fréquemment ce qui augmente la
fréquence et la gravité des inondations
côtières si on n'agit pas pour s'en
protéger est aussi l'érosion des côtes
sableuses ce que j'essaie de vous faire
passer c'est que notre rapport fournit
de nombreuses informations pour évaluer
les risques en appui à l'adaptation pour
l'europe comme pour toutes les régions
du monde avec la poursuite du
réchauffement climatique chaque région
va connaître un ensemble de changements
simultanés et multiple de changements
physiques dans le système climatique
indétendances des extrêmes des valeurs
qui peuvent dépasser les seuils de
tolérance pour les cultures pour les
animaux d'élevage même pour la santé
humaine pour le travail physique en
extérieur et ces changements seront plus
étendue et plus prononcé avec chaque
fraction de réchauffement supplémentaire
alors en europe qu'est ce que ça veut
dire par exemple ça veut dire des seuils
de chaleur critique pour la santé pour
les activités agricoles qui serait
fréquemment dépassées si le niveau de
réchauffement planétaire est plus de 2
degrés c'est aussi une augmentation des
pluies au nord de l'europe au nord de la
france mais une baisse des pluies en
particulier en été autour de la
méditerranée et en europe de l'ouest
avec une augmentation attendue des
records de précipitations mais aussi une
augmentation des sécheresses agricole
ans celle qui touche le méditer des sols
avec le niveau de réchauffement
planétaire
alors du point de vue purement de la
physique du climat comment est-ce qu'on
peut limiter le changement climatique
chaque tonne d'émissions de co2
contribuent au réchauffement de la
planète c'est le premier facteur
aujourd'hui du réchauffement ça modifie
la photosynthèse ces responsables aussi
de l'acidification de l'océan pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique à
quelques niveaux que ce soit il faut
parvenir à limiter le cumul du total des
émissions passées présentes et futures
de dioxyde de carbone et atteindre le
plus vite possible des émissions de
dioxyde de carbone liées aux activités
humaines qui sont à zéro net tant que ce
sera pas le cas le crime à continuera à
dériver et puis il faut il est
nécessaire aussi de réduire les
émissions des autres gaz à effet de
serre nous soulignons l'intérêt à agir
sur les émissions de méthane donc c'est
un gaz à effet de serre puissant c'est
le deuxième facteur aujourd'hui du
réchauffement et il contribue aussi à
augmenter la concentration d'ozone près
de la surface là où nous respirons vous
le connaissez par l'effet des pics
d'ozone qui sont néfastes pour la santé
mais aussi pour les cultures pour les
écosystèmes et donc des réductions
importantes des émissions de méthane
permettrait à la fois de limiter le
réchauffement à court terme parce quand
on l'aimé il reste seulement une dizaine
d'années dans l'air mais aussi améliorer
la qualité de l'air vous voyez en fait
que nous apportons aussi de bonnes
nouvelles au sens où une réduction
importante des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pas simplement temporaires
comme en cas de mesures de confinement
mais durable année après année par des
transformations structurelles ça
entraînerait en quelques années des
effets discernable sur les teneurs en
gaz à effet de serre sur les teneurs en
aérosol sur la qualité de l'air et puis
pour l'évolution de la température à la
surface de la terre compte tenu de la
variabilité naturelle du climat on
enverrait les bénéfices sur une
vingtaine d'années donc il est possible
de ralentir les changements
irréversibles comme la montée du niveau
des mers et d'arrêter l'intensification
des événements extrêmes en agissant sur
les causes du réchauffement et en le
limitant
peut-être le message le plus clair que
nous que nous que nous indiquons c'est
que le climat que nous connaîtrons à
l'avenir dépend des décisions que vous
prenez maintenant profondément des
décisions qui visent à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre avec
tout un enjeu de transition juste ans
mais aussi des décisions qui vise à
utiliser ses connaissances scientifiques
pour la gestion de risques pour
l'adaptation pour réduire notre
exposition et notre vulnérabilité aux
aspects inéluctable du changement
climatique j'espère que cette brève
présentation vous donnera envie de
prendre connaissance de notre résumé à
l'intention des décideurs pour l'instant
en anglais sur le site ipcc pour un ch
d'utiliser notre attrait atlas
interactif qui permet de visualiser
l'information climatique à l'échelle
régionale de récupérer les données
d'utiliser nos synthèse régionale pour
les montagnes pour l'europe pour les
petites îles pour l'océan pour les zones
urbaines et d'utiliser ses connaissances
pour éclairer vos décisions
merci beaucoup valérie merci beaucoup
ce que vous exprimez très bien également
c'est
on peut agir on peut agir en tant qu'
autorité publique on peut agir en
demandant également à tous les acteurs
de la société de répondre drastiquement
à cette urgence ce que vous évoquez
également alors là vous l'avez pas
exprimé je crois que c'est un point très
important de la question de
l'environnement c'est la biodiversité et
les études montrent que la réaction
l'action sur le climat l'action sur les
gaz interagissent également de façon
très positive vis-à-vis de la
biodiversité
oui donc l'équivalent du giec pour la
biodiversité s'appelle li baisse vous
avez certainement aussi entendu parler
de leur travail avec des points de
préoccupation très importante par
rapport à la perte de biodiversité par
rapport à ce qui touche de nombreux
écosystèmes alors il ya de nombreuses
intersections avec un climat qui change
donc plus le climat change plus la
vitesse du changement climatique est
importante en plus cela va exercer un
stress supplémentaire en plus des
pressions locales sur l'ensemble du
vivant alors je peux donner un exemple
l'océan qui est pas forcément visible
pour tous mais le changement climatique
pour l'océan c'est des vagues de chaleur
marine plus fréquentes en ce qui pèse
sur de nombreuses espèces marines alors
certaines emblématique les récifs de
coraux tropicaux mais aussi qui affecte
l'aquaculture par exemple c'est
également un océan qui se mélangent
moins bien et ce qui conduit à amener
moins d'oxygène en profondeur de l'océan
c'est un océan qui s'acidifient en
captant une partie de nos rejets de
dioxyde de carbone avec déjà une baisse
du potentiel de prises de pêche dans les
régions tropicales vous voyez que
limiter l'ampleur du réchauffement
climatique c'est important pour la vie
marine et puis toutes les sociétés
humaines qui en dépendent et c'est la
même chose sur les continents avec des
effets multiples et puis il ya des
points de vigilance c'est à dire
certaines solutions vis-à-vis du
changement climatique qui peuvent être
fondées sur la nature auront de
multiples bénéfices par exemple
restaurer les écosystèmes côtiers qui
stocke du carbone qui permettent de
limiter les effets des tempêtes et
érosion des côtes on a de multiples
bénéfices mais dans d'autres cas si par
exemple on veut agir pour le climat en
augmentant la pression sur les terres
par exemple en utilisant de l'énergie de
la biomasse pour se substituer à
d'autres sources d'énergie là on risque
d'exercer en fait des pressions
croissantes pour pas par exemple
détruire des forêts primaires les
remplacer par des cultures et c'est un
point de vigilance particulièrement
important il ya eu un atelier de
réflexion croisée climat biodiversité
qui a rendu un ensemble de
recommandations très net pour au mieux
prendre en compte ces deux dimensions
vraiment dans l'optique d'un
développement soutenable et pour
éclairer chacun des choix à la fois
longue le climat mais aussi à l'angle de
la pression sur les terres et de la
biodiversité bien sûr alors le temps
avance je vous propose de prendre deux
questions dans la salle et ensuite on
enchaînera sur sur la table suivante
alors il ya un micro je pense dans la
salle est-ce que vous pouvez levez la
main si vous avez une question
c'est toujours la première question la
plus la plus sensible
là bas
ça arrive
bonjour
ma question c'est comment se fait-il que
quand on tient ce discours pour la
réduction donc des gaz à effet de serre
on ment on le donne l'impression que
c'est notre action uniquement en france
en oubliant la chine et les états unis
juste un petit effet dans le rapport du
giec il était dit que la france
représente 1% c'est à dire qu'en gros si
on rase la france plus l'industrie on
tue tous les animaux les humains ça fait
rien globalement donc pour qu'on ne
parle jamais de la dimension
internationale alors d'abord le ce
rapport du giec n'aborde en rien les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de tel
ou tel pays par contre c'est très
clairement le cas dans les évaluations
qui sont faites par le haut conseil pour
le climat dont je suis membre donc si on
prend les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en france donc on est à peu près
1% de la population mondiale et qu'on
regarde par habitant quelles sont les
émissions en france c'est de l'ordre de
6,5 tonnes de gaz à effet de serre en
chaque année par personne et par an en
france sur le territoire national mais
quand on vit en france en on exporte et
on importe et quand on fait ce bilan net
notre empruntant par rapport à la
manière dont on vit en france en est
beaucoup plus élevé cinquante pour cent
de plus on est quasiment à 10 tonnes de
co2 équivalent de d'empreintes un lié
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
la manière dont on vit en france donc
c'est largement plus élevé que la
moyenne planétaire première chose et
donc notre contribution est plus élevé
que ce qu'on attendrait si on était dans
la moyenne planétaire deuxième chose la
question des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre elle se pose pour chaque pays
partout dans le monde bien sûr elle ne
se pose pas qu'en france mais elle se
pose partout à l'échelle de chaque
personne à l'échelle de chaque pays et
si l'on veut réduire de manière
importante les rejets de gaz à effet de
serre il est important que chaque pays y
contribuer la deuxième chose c'est que
la france s'est dotée d'objectifs
ambitieux aligné avec l'accord de paris
sur le climat dans le cadre d'une
stratégie nationale bas carbone depuis
2015 elle a échoué tenir son premier
budget carbone et le rythme actuel de
baisse des émissions purement sur le
territoire français et deux fois plus
faibles que ce à quoi elles s'étaient
engagées hors contexte de la pandémie
troisième point nous avons également une
responsabilité historique par le cumul
des émissions de dioxyde de carbone
c'est le premier facteur du
réchauffement planétaire et si on prend
la somme des émissions de co2 depuis
1750 jusqu'à aujourd'hui la france est
le huitième pays qui a eu les plus
grosses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'histoire pour cet ensemble
de raisons il est important de réfléchir
pas simplement à se dire nous ne pesons
qu'un pour cent mais à se dire nous
pesons davantage que la moyenne
planétaire nous avons la capacité à agir
si nous agissons nous allons avoir de
multiples bénéfices améliorer la qualité
de l'air par exemple ce qui est
important pour la santé publique nous
allons créer des activités économiques
compétitive nous ne serons pas les
derniers à avoir des entreprises
porteurs de solutions mais nous serons
aux avant-postes de cela et je pense que
c'est une autre manière de regarder
notre responsabilité et notre capacité à
agir et je termine en soulignant que
cette question nous ne pesons que 1%
cela fait partie d'un ensemble de
perspectives qui souvent reflète des
discours d'inaction des discours
d'inaction c'est se dire eh bien
pourquoi moi je devrais agir si les
autres n'agissent pas où je vais
attendre qu'ils aient des technologies
de rupture plutôt que déployer ce qui
existe aujourd'hui ou bien se dire je
vais attendre qu'il ya des politiques
publiques parfp est plutôt que commencer
et accélérer l'action est donc c'est
important de pas ce que simplement avoir
un discours qui justifie l'inaction mais
aussi de comprendre compte tenu de la où
on en est maintenant comment on peut
agir la france elle a une électricité
essentiellement décarbonés pas
complètement mais essentiellement
décarbonée ça c'est critique de le
conserver on a été aux avant postes pour
des raisons plus rien à voir avec le
climat dans les années 70 c'était pas
pour le climat qu'on l'a fait c'était
pour des questions d'indépendance
énergétique en particulier ça c'est
important de le conserver et ça veut
dire que chez nous à agir ben c'est
d'abord le secteur des transports 30%
des émissions puis à peu près à parts
égales l'industrie le bâtiment
l'agriculture c'est plus diffuse les
plus délicats mais tous les autres pays
vont avoir à faire avec la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de ces
secteurs et si on le fait bien si on
construit des entreprises innovantes qui
maîtrise ses savoir faire ce sera
vraiment un avantage compétitif bien sûr
et ça créera des emplois non
délocalisables
ce qui est également important
et n'oublions pas tous les interactions
qui peuvent exister entre notre pays et
les pays du monde avec notamment au
commerce international si on pense à la
chine bien sûr et s'il y avait une
deuxième question dans la salle argent
voix une par ici
bonjour à toutes et à tous ma question
est très rapide est-ce qu'on a une idée
des flux migratoires qui va y avoir au
niveau de la planète dû à ce
réchauffement et les littoraux qui
disparaissent merci alors c'est une
question qui est vraiment importante et
qui est délicate j'étais il ya deux
jours un colloque organisé par
l'université de chicago et le collège de
france en sur la question des migrations
climatiques je ne sais pas si les actes
ou les conférences de ce colloque seront
publiques donc tel que je le comprends
aujourd'hui la plupart des flux
migratoires dans le monde ne sont pas
aujourd'hui pilotée par le climat ils
proviennent essentiellement soit deux
pays pour lesquels il n'y a pas d'état
l'afghanistan la syrie la somalie haïti
et s'est donc pas d'organisation qui
permet de répondre aux besoins de base
des gens et puis ils proviennent aussi
de pays qui sont à un niveau de
développement intermédiaire où une
partie de la jeunesse qualifiée aspire à
avoir des opportunités d'emploi et
chercha à quitter ce pays tout en
apportant en fait des revenus pour la
famille restée dans ces pays alors dans
un climat qui se réchauffe bien sûr avec
la montée du niveau des mers les
événements extrêmes qui peuvent affecter
par exemple l'insécurité alimentaire ce
peut être un facteur supplémentaire de
déplacement souvent cela risque d'être
des déplacements internes au sein d'un
d'un propre pays donc des gens qui n'ont
pas de récolte qui vont quitter les
zones rurales et rejoindre la périphérie
des villes dont avec des habitats
précaires
les gens en fait on le voit déjà dans
certains pays sur le littoral on voit
que les gens qui ont des revenus qui se
déplace un peu plus à l'intérieur des
terres et puis ceux qui restent sur la
frange la plus exposée aux aléas sur le
vraiment à proximité immédiate du niveau
des mers sont les plus précaires les
plus fragiles donc cela fait partie des
points qui sont je pense importants qui
font partie des risques liés au climat
et au delà de ce rapport que je
décrivais 1 sur les bases physiques il
ya bien sûr un état des lieux qui a été
fait ces dernières années sur d'autres
dimensions de risques donc j'ai souligné
les enjeux pour la sécurité en nous
qu'ils sont particulièrement importants
dans les zones de climat méditerranéen
et semi arides il ya des enjeux très
importants en matière de sécurité
alimentaire également en fonction à la
fois du niveau de développement du
niveau de réchauffement mais aussi du
type de développement que l'on choisit
est ce que je veux souligner par là
c'est qu'il est possible d'agir à la
fois en maîtrisant le réchauffement
climatique mais aussi par les choix en
matière de développement la lutte contre
l'extrême pauvreté la maîtrise du type
de demande alimentaire peut permettre de
renforcer la sécurité alimentaire même
si la population mondiale va continuer à
augmenter ces prochaines décennies donc
ce n'est pas seulement une histoire de
climat c'est beaucoup plus profond le
fait de parvenir à limiter ces risques
croisés
merci beaucoup valérie je propose qu'on
continue et qu'on commence notre table
ronde écologie humaniste je vous propose
d'applaudir une nouvelle fois valérie
merci pour sa participation
valérie si vous souhaitez vous pouvez
rester avec nous et écouter ce débat
j'appelle à me rejoindre sur la scène
erwan balanant
au de l'udc et mais je crois qu'elle est
un petit peu en retard jimmy pahun bruno
myle yens et richard ramos merci
[Musique]
aux nous rejoindra dès qu'elle sera
arrivé dans la salle qu'on a une table
très masculine désolé aux deux
basculera un petit peu voilà
cinq députés cinq députés du modem qui
porte ce que je crois être important
pour notre famille c'est à dire cette
écologie humaniste que nous prônons
depuis 2007
chacun d'entre eux portent et porte
cette image et porte des des sujets
importants donc je vais je vais appeler
chacun en fait à proposer voilà sa
vision et ensuite on pourrait avoir un
échange avec la salle donc tout d'abord
jimmy pahun qui ancien skipper
journaliste sportif député de la
deuxième circonscription du morbihan
alors on est on est chez lui également
membre de la commission du développement
durable et de l'aménagement
alors il met tous toutes ces compétences
liées au monde maritime ou à la mer dans
son travail au niveau du parlement du
parlement et je voudrais voilà lui lui
proposait d'exprimer un petit peu sa
vision notamment de la question des
océans aujourd'hui ce que c'est un
thermomètre climatique et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour pour améliorer la
situation merci david de pépi de me
donner le micro pour quelques instants
effectivement et je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment pris en
compte au plus haut sommet de l'état le
président de la république ne manquent
pas une intervention que ce soit au g7
que ce soir à lui et à lui sienne que ce
soit
aux assises du monde maritime pour
parler de l'océan il a mis en place un
ministère de la mer donc on est vraiment
préoccupée et on sait que on dit souvent
qu'une respiration tu redeviens de
l'océan et madame delmotte a parlé tout
à l'heure du rapport du giec maritime
qui a été fait il ya droit qu'il ya deux
trois ans deux choses - 20 tout est
quand même préoccupant
le réchauffement de l'eau donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya une montée de la faune et
de la flore qui montons on n'avait
jamais vu des thons rouges en atlantique
il ya quelques années maintenant on en
voit l'acidification des océans et ça ça
nous embête un petit peu ça nous embête
énormément parce que c'est plancton et
le plancton
c'est la base de 2,2 du de l'écosystème
de voile en vivant du vivant le
dérèglement climatique aussi tu sais pas
ce qu'on fait avec nous dans
l'hémisphère nord le dérèglement
climatique il est le schéma est assez
simple en fait ses valises et qui ce qui
se fait du côté de de l'afrique et qui
reprend un petit peu le gulf stream et
le golf rim qui est inquiète un courant
qui qui qui gèrent très très bien le des
températures et on sent qu'il ya des
dérèglements au niveau du gulfstream un
petit réchauffement du gulf stream des
ouragans bien plus fréquent dans dents
dans les pays tant que sur l'arc
antillais et puis des tempêtes parfois
un peu plus violente alors moi je on a
d'abord on hamm
est une sonde édition qui doivent se
prendre qu'à l'échelle internationale
quoi et le président de la république
dans son discours de biarritz avait
soumis voilà voilà aude avait soumis une
proposition très simple
le président de la république avait
soumis une proposition une proposition
très simple qui était la réduction de
vitesse des navires de commerce
tous les navires de commerce qui ne
transporte pas des denrées périssables
pouvait réduire un petit peu leur
vitesse d'autant qu'il y en a tellement
ils sont tellement en attente dont des
ports que ça nous permettrait de faire
une économie de 40 millions de tonnes de
gaz à effet de serre et ça je sais que
c'est un combat sur lequel le brio de la
république se bat et sur lequel notre
haut commissaire au plan également
françois se bat il est en échanges
fréquents avec les armateurs de france
pour que cette idée soit portée au
niveau de l' oms qui est l'office
maritime intello et middle-office
maritime international donc voilà ce qui
est fait nous au modem où est ce qu'il
est patrick mignola kim que je rappelle
quand même qu'on a quand même porté une
proposition de loi pour essayer de
trouver un statut juridique à ce qu'on
appelle la haute mer à tout ce qui est
au delà des 500 milles et pour l'instant
n'a pas de statut juridique tout ce qui
est au delà de tout ce qui est au delà
des 500 milles et nous avions propos de
proposer au modem une proposition pour
une résolution une ppr afin que ce soit
porté sur le plan politique parce que
c'est la seule discussion qui a
actuellement à à l'onu cette ce pc des
glacières du bibi angie donc de cette
portabilité portabilité sur la haute mer
et voilà un petit peu ce que ce que
j'avais à dire mais il faut l'océan il
faut le regarder de très près parce que
c'est un capteur de carbone capitale
alors il ya des bonnes nouvelles il ya
des bonnes nouvelles
ah et après j'arrête il ya sept cette
demande du président de la république
d'aires protégées terrestres et marines
à objectif de 30% et de 10% forte et 2
5% méditerranée avant 2027 a été
annoncée au congrès de lui et de lui
viennent et puis moi j'étais hier à
nantes un atelier où on ne racontaient
que que la qualité des eaux des deux au
port de plaisance méditerranéen était
bien meilleure maintenant qu'il y a
trente ans donc il ya quand même des
efforts qui sont faits il faut qu'on
aide nos pays voisins il faut qu'on ait
nos pays voisins on en parlera demain le
plastique est une vraie catastrophe
il faut qu'on ait nos pays voisins à
mieux gérer leurs déchets et à ce que la
méditerranée puisse se régénérer
régulièrement voila voila en gros en
gros
l'importance de l'océan et je suis très
gêné par de très belles preuves et merci
madame delmotte
on a quand même trois outils
fantastiques on associait qu ce giec
c'est 200 chercheurs au monde ne publie
que si les 200 1899 autres sont d'accord
sur leur publication à la virgule près
donc ce sont des gens qui savent ce
qu'ils font il faut qu'on les écoute et
puis on a deux outils qu était
fantastique on a le grenelle de
l'environnement
on me dit j'ai deux petites dames qui
s'appelait madame gauthier c'est pas une
petite dame c'est une dame qui plaît
madame gauthier qui était directrice du
conservatoire du littoral qui musée mais
jimmy nous avons tous avec le grenelle
de l'environnement et les accords de
paris donc il faut qu'on se tient à
saint bruno vous en parlerai tout tout à
l'heure on a passé une loi superbe on a
passé une loi superbe que la loi anti
gaspi économie circulaire et ils vont
parler ils vont en parler et il faut que
les décrets suivent voilà ce que j'avais
à vous dire et dernière petite chose
vous dire que béline au maire a proposé
aux prisonniers public d'accueillir le
wan ho shon summit qui se tiendra en
janvier et février
je trouve que ce serait un très très
beau symbole que de le faire à belle-ile
merci beaucoup jimmy alors ça rigole sur
la table parce que applaudissez vous
pouvez l'applaudir
ça rigole sur la table parce que on a
ici cinq causeur alors ils prennent tous
beaucoup et on va essayer de tenir les
temps
merci beaucoup s'est mis alors
l'introduction de valérie était très
intéressante parce qu'elle permet de
comprendre la problématique existe
aujourd'hui et ensuite on à
l'application que j'ai voulu de façon on
va dire un peu graduelle c'est à dire du
global l'océan au plus local donc je
propose maintenant à erwan balanant qui
est député de la 8e circonscription du
finistère alors nous sommes voisins
presque qui manquent de la commission
des lois de la délégation aux droits des
femmes et qui a été rapporteur sur le
projet de loi de la climat et résilience
donc l'application d'un projet citoyen
d'une convention citoyenne donc là on
est sur du national voire même au delà
et je propose à erwan de nous de nous
parler un petit peu justement de comment
on applique des discussions et des
résolutions citoyenne dans la boue oui
alors merci et merci david merci à tout
le monde alors tout à l'heure j'étais
pas du tout en retard jeu pour ceux qui
m'ont chambré j'étais juste avec la
ministre et nous n'étions en visite
ministérielle dans ma circonscription
ce n'était pas du tout un retard de ma
part alors sur la question de
l'environnement et sur la question qui
nous
qui nous préoccupe définir une écologie
humaniste c'est quoi c'est important que
notre mouvement le définit str et tu me
lance sur la convention citoyenne vous
avez vu la convention citoyenne volonté
du président volonté aussi d'un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui souhaitait
que cette convention se met en place et
on a vu que cette convention qui s'est
tenue pendant
presque dix mois qui a fait un travail
monstrueux a fait un certain nombre de
propositions des propositions parfois
fortes radicales
la plupart utile et la plupart
à mettre en oeuvre
n'ont pas toujours été mise en oeuvre
exactement à la lettre comme l'aurait
imaginé les conventionnels est sacrée et
ça a pu créer un peu de
tension tension largement évidemment
comment dire instrumentalisé par nos
oppositions enfin le constat il est là
c'est que ce texte de la convention
climat et le texte des démocraties
de toutes les démocraties le texte le
plus avancé sur la protection de
l'environnement et sur la protection et
les fins sur la le cap pour décarbonés
alors est-ce qu'on a été assez loin
sans doute pas puisque madame
masson-delmotte l'a dit on partait de
tellement loin et on a pris tellement de
retard puisque les questions de climat
si on s'y était engagé ya trente ans on
aurait certainement moins de
préoccupation maintenant mais ce que je
veux dire par là si on veut réfléchir à
la définition de ce que pourrait être
une écologie humaniste
déjà je pense que c'est une et
l'écologie de gouvernement et j'entends
dans les débats des gens que je côtoie
depuis longtemps les écologistes qui
nous disent que il faut que ça soit
radical et certains qui disent ça ne
peut pas être une écologie de
gouvernement mais si c'est si ce n'est
pas une écologie de gouvernement ça veut
dire qu'elle va pas se faire
ça veut dire qu'il aura pas de décisions
politiques prises autour de cette
écologie et nous c'est une des
différences que nous avons nous voulons
que cette écologie elle soit réelle et
que les décisions exister que des lois
les encadrent si si on dit il faut être
radicale et l'écologie ne peut pas être
de gouvernement je suis désolé on arrive
très vite à une impasse c'est à dire
qu'on ne va rien faire et nous justement
nous voulons faire alors comment on peut
faire déjà on al houthi du giec est
l'outil du giec qui nous dit quelque
chose qui est très simple et il faut que
tout le monde l'est en tête baisser nos
émissions carbone est non négociable
ce n'est c'est non négociable
une fois qu'on a dit ça
on a tout dit on n'a rien dit et tout le
travail maintenant et ça sera le travail
que nous allons mener tous ensemble les
militants engagés et je remercie david
parce que david avec démocrates pour la
planète il fait un super boulot auprès
des militants pour justement faire
remonter la force militante sur ces
questions là nous le parti les
parlementaires eh bien il faut qu'on
soit force de proposition il est fort
force de proposition c'est d'être très
sérieux quand on travaille quand on
travaille autour de l'écologie on a
quelque chose qui est non négociable
baisser nos émissions carbone maintenant
comment on le fait eh ben on le fait
avec sérieux et on il faut moi c'est un
projet et un combat que je porte et la
plupart de mes collègues également il
nous faut des outils d'évaluation des
politiques publiques
comment si on n'évalue pas les décisions
que l'on prend sur tel ou tel sujet de
décarbonation si on ne sait pas quel
gain carbone ça nous fait qu'elle sait
telle mesure nous fait gagner combien de
carbone telle autre nous ont fait perdre
et tout ça il faut avoir des outils de
pilotage on a un outil pilotage macro
qui est le giec est maintenant il faut
que dans notre pays on est ces outils
d'évaluation c'est pour ça que moi je
prône pour qu'on ait et j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi sur le sujet une
évaluation climatique des lois c'est à
dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on a une loi
qui est qui a une capacité d'avoir un
impact on est les outils d'évaluation de
cette loi ça c'est le point extrêmement
important et puis on a un point je
laissais mes mes camarades en parler
l'idée qu'on a porté pendant la loi
climat résilience l'idée de travailler
sur les engagements volontaires et quand
je dis engagement volontaire c'est que
les entreprises s'engagent et s'engage
fortement et s'engage avec des objectifs
et si on engage pas j'ai dix entreprises
mais c'est également tous les citoyens
il faut que cette question du climat il
ya un engagement écueil est une commande
hier une une envie commune de chaque
citoyen de le faire parce que les
décisions
étatiques pouvoirs publics sont
importantes on a une responsabilité
collective à mettre en place mais on a
aussi une responsabilité individuelle de
chacun d'entre nous mais tout ça ne sera
possible que si nous avons des outils
pour évaluer sa des outils de pilotage
que l'on puisse faire
quand on prend une décision quand on a
un débat sur un texte qu'on puisse avoir
des éléments très précis je conclus par
un exemple savez on a fait une loi une
loi formidable qui s'appelait la loi
pacte comme toutes les lois que nous
avons il ya ce qu'on appelle un comment
dire une évaluation des textes il ya un
gros gros il ya une étude d'impact
pardon mais l'étude d'impact qui est
publié avec la loi c'est l'étude
d'impact de la loi au moment où elle
arrive au conseil des ministres s'est
laissée sur les 300 articles qu'il y
avait initialement sauf que quand on
fait notre travail parlementaire n'en
transforme de ses articles on en rajoute
parfois 200 sur cette loi la joie qui a
eu 200 amendements supplémentaires 200
articles pardon donc ses 200 articles
supplémentaires ils sont pas évalués
donc ils sont pas évalués donc on sait
pas ce que ça vaut donc moi par exemple
dans ce travail je pense qu'il faut
qu'on avance sur ses outils de pilotage
voilà je vais pas être plus long mais
j'ai déjà été trop long il a raison on
est un peu des causes heures mais on est
aussi des faiseurs dans ce mouvement et
on a fait beaucoup de choses pour sur la
loi climat et résilience et ça fera la
transition sans doute c'est que vous
êtes voici des gens passionnés j'entends
cela on a on a fait bien avancer ce
texte et on va continuer sur le sujet
parce que je voulais dit c'est non
négociable
donc effectivement bruno myle yens
député de la 9e circonscription des
yvelines qui a défendu alors depuis
toujours la question du local du rural
il est membre de la commission
développement durable également et vice
président du groupe modem et apparentés
à l'assemblée nationale bruno
il a tendu une perche j'ai envie de dire
tu vas pouvoir voir exprimer un petit
peu ta vision merci david bonsoir à
toutes et à tous ce qui est important
alors pourquoi on va parler du rural et
des territoires parce que vous voyez
aujourd'hui que toutes les politiques
publiques la plupart des politiques
publiques se développent très très bien
je vais pas opposer les rurales aux
métropolitains je vous rassure mais je
vais vous donner deux trois chiffres si
on prend le bilan par exemple de la
région ile de france lors du dernier
membre de la dernière mandature sur 100%
de l'économie enfin du bilan économique
assure 100%
d'engagement économique en ile-de-france
70% l'ont été sur paris et la petite
couronne et 30 % uniquement sur la
deuxième couronne qui est déjà la
ruralité ça vous fait rire quand je vous
parle de ruralité moi qui suis
franciliens mais j'invite tout le monde
à venir dans ma circonscription qui est
excessivement rural moi j'ai une grande
ville c'est des bureaux et après la
quasi totalité de mes commune des 87
communes sont en dessous des 3500
habitants donc les territoires sont
importants à plusieurs choses d'abord
parce que on a une chance énorme je
crois que jimmy et roanne - peu évoqué
une chance énorme c'est que ce qui se
passe actuellement dans notre pays cette
obligation qui nous est faite parce
qu'on n'a pas su réagir à temps de
baisser effectivement nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de travailler sur
l'économie circulaire et contre le
gaspillage
implique forcément quand on va voir une
économie verte qu'on va pouvoir
déplacer sur les territoires et déplacé
cette économie verte sur les territoires
je veux dire simplement ce que ça amène
s'amène simplement qu'on casse cette
fameuse diagonale du vide dont on parle
depuis des années et qui est quand même
à l'origine des fractures sociales dans
notre pays vous l'avez vu avec le gilet
avec le gilet jaune ces parties des
territoires c'est pas partie des
métropoles ou de la périurbanisation
pourquoi ces partis d'été à tort parce
que ces gens là et je le sais puisque je
le vis dans ma circonscription ces gens
là se sentent déclassé alors après elle
m'a dit quelque chose qui est très
important c'est l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
au niveau national ça c'est important de
le faire c'est le rôle du parlement mais
il faut qu'on fasse aussi une évaluation
des politiques publiques dans nos
départements sur nos territoires parce
que c'est pas quand on aura évalué au
niveau national c'est bien d'évaluer au
niveau national on va dire ah ben là ça
marche là ça marche pas bon on sera pas
trop pourquoi en fait et à ce niveau là
je pense que effectivement ce
gouvernement a encore bien travaillé
puisque amélie de montchanin a créé un
petit outil absolument fantastique qui
vous permet d'aller évaluer les
politiques publiques dans chaque
département secteur par secteur
l'environnement est compris dedans et
vous pouvez voir si votre département
est en avance ou en retard sur les
objectifs fixés par les politiques
publiques et vous êtes en droit du coup
d'interpeller d'interroger à la fois les
services déconcentrés de l'état mais
aussi les élus locaux pour savoir
pourquoi ça avance et pourquoi ça
n'avance pas et pourquoi c'est très
important je vais vous donner juste un
exemple sur ma circonscription dans une
ancienne commune très ouvrière qui
s'appelle bonnières sur seine
j'avais une entreprise j'ai bien j'avais
envie encore mais pas pour très
longtemps j'avais une entreprise
fantastique qui s'appelle skytech
skytech fait du recyclage plastique à
99,7 %
ça ça doit parler à jean
99 7% du plastique qui arrive chez eux
et recyclés et recyclés et tous types de
plastiques et on se dit on a toujours
entendu dire que le plastique recyclé
était plus chère que le plastique
pétrolier est bien eux ils revendent ce
plastique là aux entreprises 30% moins
cher 30% moins cher que le plastique
pétrolier est bien cette entreprise là
ma circonscription et mon département on
va la perdre on va la perdre parce que
nos élus locaux auront été incapables de
faire une meilleure offre que le
département d'à côté qui les récupèrent
pas ce qu'ils vont s'agrandir ils vont
passer à 40 mille mètres carrés parce
que ça y est le pli est pris ils ont des
commandes ils sont en pleine expansion
et on comprend pourquoi et ça ça
concourt donc aussi à
comment à l'évaluation des politiques
publiques territoriale et moi je
regrette vraiment totalement que qu'on
laisse partir cette entreprise au niveau
local donc il ya des combats à mener
effectivement au niveau national c'est
ce qu'on fait nous tous mais on ne perd
jamais de vue il faut jamais perdre de
vue comment on les transforme sur les
territoires parce que c'est important je
vais finir sur le téléthon avec un tout
petit mot sur l'agriculture parce que
richard on parlera peut-être beaucoup
mieux que moi mais si on regarde le
rapport du giec au niveau climatologique
en 2050 en ile de france on fera du très
bon bordeaux
on fera de l'excellent bordeaux
je sais pas ce que feront les bordelais
mais nous on fera d'excellents bordeaux
ils feront du porte haut les bordelais
donc c'est vous dire si
le rafale au réchauffement climatique le
changement climatique est important et
là on a une vraie question à se poser
est cette question d'être posée au
niveau des territoires on a un
accompagnement
fantastique à faire au niveau des
agriculteurs et pas question d'y montrer
du doigt ou de les stigmatiser il faut
les accompagner travailler avec eux de
ce qu'on peut faire des terres qui nous
reste dans quel état elles sont qu'est
ce qu'on va faire demain on a vu arriver
mais je compte donc nous c'est arrivé
aussi dans le val de loire tu me diras
si je me trompe ou pas dabo coude
agriculteurs qu'ils aient des terrains
qui font du sort aux faucons
accompagnent ces gens là dans la
transition pas en les stigmatisant
pas en leur disant leur donnant des
ordres par leur exemple tu vas faire si
tu vas faire ça mais parce que
scientifiquement en travaillant avec eux
on va les amener vers une autre
agriculture qui sera d'abord plus
respectueuse de l'environnement ça on le
sait mais qui sera aussi plus
respectueuse de l'avenir de
l'agriculture qu'on veut qu'on veut
mettre dans notre pays parce que ce
réchauffement climatique il existe de
toute façon donc c'est très important de
rester accrochés à nos territoires de
travailler avec tous les secteurs de nos
territoires pour mettre en place dans
nos territoires toutes ces mesures qu'on
doit mettre en place et encore j'ai
oublié plein de choses j'ai oublié les
tourbières j'ai oublié l'eau qui est un
sujet très important on va bientôt avoir
la conclusion du varennes de l'eau d'ici
à d'ici à la fin de la fin de l'année
on va prendre aussi dans la globalité
avant on avait traité que les trucs de
manière séparée là on va prendre en tout
dans la globalité en prenant tous les
acteurs de l'eau comment récupérer cette
eau qui repart à la mer on va voir de
plus en plus de
dix noms dation il ya de l'eau qui
repart à la mairie qu'on la récupère il
faut qu'on la récupère pour la donner à
nos agriculteurs mais pour sauvegarder
notre eau potable il faut qu'on la
traite mieux va tous ces sujets là c'est
des sujets de territoires sur lesquels
on ne cessera de travailler et qui doit
faire partie de l'équation je l'espère
du prochain quinquennat du président
macro
alors effectivement la question du local
elle est importante et on le voit bien
dans nos territoires il est également la
question des freins des freins qui
peuvent exister auprès des collectivités
auprès des citoyens après la population
alors là dessus je voudrais donner la
parole à aude dont député de la première
circonscription de seine-et-marne qui
est vice présidente également du groupe
modem et apparentés membre de la
commission développement durable avec
une spécialité sur la mobilité aude a
voulu nous exprimer un peu plus la
question justement delà des
collectivités et de comment on traite la
question de ses freins dans dans une
écologie qui est une écologie
d'applications une écologie du quotidien
merci bonjour à toutes et à tous d'abord
je souhaitais m'excuser du retard alors
je n'avais pas de visites ministérielles
je viens de melun donc j'ai eu un peu
ici il ya des mobilités mais bon c'était
un petit peu un petit peu plus long que
prévu oui alors j'ai loupé les
interventions
madame delmotte donc moi ce que je
voulais vous dire par rapport à ce qui a
été dit à la fois par par erwan et puis
par par bruno je crois qu'il faut voir
c'est la résonance qu'on leur peut avoir
sur sur nos coûts sur nos communes sur
la façon dont on peut avoir cette
déclinaison de ce que nous avons votée
nous au parlement sur les différentes
lois qu'on nous avons proposé et on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas aussi simple
que ça et qui a nécessité d'
accompagnement c'est à dire qu'on peut
avoir toutes les bonnes volontés du
monde on s'aperçoit hébreu nous le
disait qu'on a quand même beaucoup de
communes qui sont rurales et qui ont pas
les moyens de mettre en place et
d'appliquer en tous les cas ce que nous
nous votons puisque c'est un manque d
ingénierie c'est un des freins qu'on
peut qu on peut noter on peut voir aussi
qu'au niveau financier avec le
coronavirus il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
moins de recettes beaucoup plus de
dépenses pour un certain nombre de
communes donc il ya cet accompagnement
qu'on doit avoir et je crois qu'il ya
aussi on a un défi social puisque
je suis donc de melun melun 40000
habitants avec un quartier en
quartier de politique de la ville avec
des personnes qui ne vont pas de toute
façon se tourner vers une écologie enfin
tout le cas vers une consommation
beaucoup plus
va dire qui sera beaucoup plus
protectrice qui sera dans l'amélioration
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas le
voir et c'est une question que moi j'ai
parce que je ne sais pas comment on va
les accompagner puisqu'on n'aura pas les
moyens financiers les communes n'ont pas
ne les ont pas et nous c'est vrai qu'on
n'est sur la nécessité de faire mieux
d'avoir cette loi climat résilience sur
les gaspillages sur et galim sur un
certain nombre de choses on est on a
effectivement pris des positions pour
dire qu'il fallait en tous les cas à
protéger baisser les gaz à effet de
serre faire en sorte que les mobilités
soit soient aussi prises en compte mais
comme le disait aussi david les
mobilités dans et bruno sûrement y lirez
dans mon sens les mobilités dans l'est
dans les communes rurales c'était un
excellent on a le plus besoin de voiture
pour se déplacer pour aller travailler
donc on éloigne de plus en plus l'école
et on va dire les là où nous habitons
par rapport à l'homme nous travaillons
et c'est vrai que ça reste un
questionnement moi je reviens sur ce que
je vous disais il ya quelques temps
cessé de se dire comment nous
accompagnons ses compagnons des
personnes qui avons donc ne pas ne peut
qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'alimenter qui
vont pas aller à le faire du bio qui
vont pas pouvoir aller acheter s'acheter
une voiture or aujourd'hui qu'une diesel
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres moyens
qu'ils ont
voilà ce sont des questionnements que
nous devons avoir et que
je rejoins aussi l'aspect d'évaluation
des politiques publiques c'est à dire
que toute action publique nécessite une
évaluation publique qu'elle soit au
niveau national mais aussi au niveau
local et aujourd'hui c'est pas quelque
chose qui est dans l'esprit en tout
l'état des collectivités territoriales
des mères qui ne n'ont pas les moyens ou
qui ne veulent pas de toute façon à
évaluer cercle le temps le temps
électoral fait que tous les six ans eh
bien on va on va faire différemment et
on se préoccupe pas de savoir si ce
qu'on met en place va être pertinent ou
pas pertinent et ça je crois que c'est
assez je sais pas comment on peut
répondre alors il ya eu la convention
citoyenne et c'est vrai que c'était
intéressant parce que certains citoyens
se sont engagés sur sur des propositions
et je crois qu'on en a pris une grande
partie même si c'était pas comme l'a dit
erwan vraiment les mêmes exactement les
mêmes et on s'est quand même engagé mais
au-delà de ces conventions citoyenne il
faut quand même qu on ait conscience que
l'on doit avoir cette écologie humaniste
c'est le thème de cette de cet échange
les manies ça veut dire qu'on prend en
compte et qu'on hausse entre l'humain et
il ya tout ce questionnement des
personnes qui ne sont pas en capacité
d'aller vers cette écologie d'aller vers
cette démarche vers ces actions où elles
seront effectivement capable de de se
déplacer de se loger
de manger différemment de ce show fait
différemment et ça c'est une grande
inquiétude aussi que nous pouvons avoir
et j'aimerais juste conclure sur le fait
que lorsqu'on voit que les collectivités
mettent en place un certain nombre de
grands projets et j'avais effectivement
quand nous avons auditionné le haut
commissaire au plan donc françois bayrou
sur le sujet on a aujourd'hui des
projets qui date de 10 à 15 ans et on
s'aperçoit que ces projets sont plus
aujourd'hui en adéquation à ce que nous
avec ce que nous vivons alors que des
investissements étaient engagés pardon
et que nous sommes nous sommes plus
forcément capable de revenir en arrière
ou en tous les cas que le projet qui va
être proposée n'est plus en phase donc
on a encore énormément de travail à
faire
on a cette grande volonté mais je crois
que localement alors je sais pas comment
ça se passe chez vous mais localement on
reste encore sur la suite de l'agenda 21
dans certains endroits la mise en place
d'un comité local de transition
écologique et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une réponse mais c'est pas
suffisant pour qu'on soit efficace et
pour qu'on prenne en compte le
changement qu'on doit avoir dans nos
comportements geste un dernier exemple à
melun ville de 40000 habitants il ya
deux bornes électriques voilà donc ça
veut dire qu'on a quand même un chemin à
faire un budget de plus de 150 millions
d'euros nous avons deux bornes
électriques autant qu'une commune qui
est qu'à 500 habitants qui s'appelle
valence en brie et voilà vous savez
c'est c'est aussi cette c'est la
transformation des mentalités alors des
citoyens mais il faut qu'ils soient eux
aussi accompagnés par les élus et par
les moyens qu'on pourra avoir autour
alors effectivement on a pu voir depuis
le début de cette table à quel point la
question du développement durable est
une question à la fois techniques à la
fois sur l'application et peut-être
cette difficulté à
véhiculer un message
donc écologie humaniste je propose à
richard ramos dont qui est bien connu
chez nous à la fois pour s'être illustré
sur de nombreux combats liés
effectivement au territoire mais
également en tant que secrétaire général
adjoint du modem alors il est député de
la 6e circonscription du loiret membre
de la commission affaires économiques
mais alors voilà richard peut être pour
une sorte de petite conclusion déjà de
cette table avant d'échanger avec le
public qu'est-ce que nous par rapport à
ces à ses premiers propos qu'est ce que
nous en tant que modem on peut porter
comme écologie humaniste et quel message
on peut envoyer aux gens oui alors
d'abord content de voir dans la salle
beaucoup de gens que j'ai j'ai croisé
hauteur de mes voyages j'ai envie de
dire et mes péripéties pour défendre la
proximité et la ruralité
manger local et donc on a autant de
combattants dans cette salle que il y en
a sur cette scène moi ce que ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que je vais
passer vite sur l'alimentation on a fait
le travail qu'on devait faire on a
appris on était des jeunes députés mais
on peut être à peu près fier du travail
qu'on a fait mais c'est plus
qu'insuffisant
on a gagné des batailles dont on nous
disait qu'elle n'était pas gagnable moi
je me rappelle quand un grand groupe
industriel pour pas le nommer qui
s'appelle lactalis on me dit dans
l'ensemble des camemberts france des
camemberts français et de toutes les aop
française on va pouvoir mettre du lait
pasteurisé c'est à dire de balayer d'un
revers de main le goût d'un terroir le
morceau de france sur lequel on fabrique
un produit parce qu'on veut faire plus
de fric parce qu'on s'en fiche de la
race qu'il produit parce qu'on s'en
fiche du coup parce que on veut
mobiliser les goûts parce qu en
modélisant les goûts on modélise les
coûts et dans la tête de ces gens là que
je rencontrais je pensais moi que si on
pensait à manger tous la même chose si
on mangeait tous la même chose on
finirait par nous faire penser tous la
même chose et donc ses combats là on les
a menés ils sont violents et oui à une
violence écologique où il combat
écologique n'est pas de tout repos et
donc au moment où on était là je
recevais
par sms
un message du patron duke à 23 millions
de français l'ont téléchargé je suis
dans tous les procès pour défendre duka
camp luka dit quand vous mangez de la
charcuterie avec du cern et rites et il
ya un risque de mourir d'un cancer
colorectal et je peux avoir une pensée
on peut avoir une pensée parce qu'il a
été souvent sur ses estrades là axel
kahn pour nous pour m'avoir accompagné
en dix ans richard ça tu mets les
puissants sont là il tend pêcheront et
nous empêcherons d'y arriver et donc une
faut pas se tromper que ce soit sur
l'alimentation ou sur l'écologie les
lobbyistes et les technocrates sont
souvent main dans la main pour nous
empêcher d'avancer au nom de l'argent au
nom que l'économique ils passeront
toujours eu devant le politique et je
pense que notre mouvement politique
chaque citoyen où chacun d'entre vous a
sa carte bleue qui est bien puis plus
sans pardon qu'un bulletin de vote dans
son acte dans ton acte quotidien nous
devons aller au combat sur ces
affaires-là je pense que le modem avait
dans son adn l'écologie imaginez les
jaunes les gens aujourd'hui qui court
après l'écologie
la structure juridique du modem
juridique trois composantes à l'époque
4,21 l'udf et les citoyens par les inter
en direct ça veut dire que dans notre
adn avant tout le monde nous avions
compris la transversalité de l'écologie
et ses combats là qui sont devant nous
sont des combats que nous devrons mener
avec force parce que nous aurons
toujours en face de nous des gens qui
nous empêcheront d'y arriver
quand aujourd'hui on se bagarre sur des
textes de loi très souvent nous avons
des freins qui sont des freins qui ne
sont pas des freins de bon sens ce sont
des freins économiques quand on me dit
si on retire on retire pas le seul
nitrites et dans la charcuterie
attention dessus ramos oui le cirque a
dit que c'était cancérogènes et que
c'est dangereux mais attention l
économie qu il faut regarder aussi le
nombre d'emplois dont acte mais peut-on
encore produire des produits dont on
sait qu'ils tuent les français et
notamment les plus pauvres peut-on
laisser également dans l'esprit
écologique que les plus pauvres eux ne
pourraient pas avoir des produits sains
c'est à dire là par exemple
pouvoir continuer à manger les produits
nitrites et en sachant qu'il meure en
sachant que tous les industriels sont en
train de fabriquer des produits avec les
labels écolos avec des produits qui
auront également des marges supérieures
et donc ils fabriqueront deux
alimentations et donc l'écologique et
celle du modem ça doit être l'écologie
pour tous
autrefois les riches manger de la viande
les pauvres manger des légumes
aujourd'hui les les riches mange des
légumes les pauvres mangent de la viande
sauf qu'on leur viande on leur donne de
la viande qui aujourd'hui n'est pas de
qualité et donc il faut qu'on se bat
ensemble pour ces affaires là et je
pense pour conclure que notre mouvement
politique doit placer l'écologie non pas
dans un discours que je ne supporte plus
en disant qu'il y aurait une écologie
positive les autres aider des gens des
hommes des cavernes est-ce que moi on a
besoin de nous de se présenter comme
écologiste par rapport aux écologistes
secteur ce que fait la droite regardez
la droite à chaque fois dit oui mais
nous on y l'écologie positive mais
qu'est-ce que vous - merdé été dites ce
que vous êtes ne vous définissez pas par
les autres ça veut bien dire que vous
n'avez pas conceptualiser votre idée de
l'économie de l'écologie humaniste nous
nous savons d'où nous venons l'homme est
au coeur du système notre projet projet
arras qui est qu'il n'ya pas une ligne a
changé de ce qu'on a écrit à l'époque
c'est de méteren et la femme au milieu
de la cité au milieu de la nature avec
le respect de la nature et donc je pense
que le défi qui est devant le nôtre
aujourd'hui que le groupe modem
aujourd'hui que vous dans les
territoires on est installé au nous
avons nous a chanté nous avait vus dans
les élections à on veut pas de nous
souvent dans s'installe on n'est jamais
aussi fort que quand on est au combat on
n'est jamais aussi fort que quand le
modem est libre et je pense que dans les
années qui viennent le modem écologistes
fera en sorte que ce seront nous au
milieu qui porteront ces belles valeurs
merci merci à vous 5 je propose qu'on
passe aux questions de la salle on va
prendre deux trois questions à la fois
alors je vous propose de lever la main
et les microbes ont circulé alors il ya
déjà une première là bas
bonjour les côtes je suis agriculteur
dont vous pensez bien que je suis
extrêmement intéressé par ce que parce
que vous avez dit je voudrais vous vous
demandez ce que vous pensez de
l'instauration du marché du carbone
avec la création d'une sorte de bourse
c'est à dire que les gens vertueux
bénéficieront d'un crédit et ceux qui le
sont moins vont payer je veux savoir ce
que vous pensez de ça
alors on va prendre peut-être deux trois
questions à la fois comme ça vu que vous
êtes 5 vous pouvez répondre à une autre
question devant là je crois
ou
peut-être
bonsoir
je voulais poser une question sur la loi
climat résilience donc je suis jean paul
michaux je suis président d'un scot de
l'agglomération briques bisontine est
donc dans la loi climat de résilience on
a on traite d'urbanisme et en
particulier de la zero artificialisation
net donc c'est un objectif zéro
artificialisation net c'est pour 2050
donc ça sera vite là avec une diminution
d'ici les dix ans qui viennent de 50% de
l'artificialisation donc pour ne plus
consommer de la terre agricole je pense
que c'est quelque chose de très
important
simplement messieurs mesdames les
députés je voulais attirer votre
attention sur la nécessité
en même temps qu'eux ont pressé de ces
lois d'accompagnement qui lie à des
accompagnements fiscaux pour que nous
derrière on puisse en mettre en oeuvre
les pôles des politiques qu'ils soient
donc des bonnes politiques et c'est
c'est eh voilà c'était dans cette
intervention dans ce sens là merci
merci ce qu'il ya une troisième question
à ça
bonjour vincent de 60 mois c'est enfin
que c'est une réflexion qu'une question
en elle même c'est comment tordre et on
vous dit j'ai déjà notre nos propres
administrations à respecter les lois
écologiques qu'on a fait voter par
exemple ça fait six ans j'ai enfin
réussi je me suis battu j'ai réussi là
mais au bout de six ans de matane à
faire en sorte qu'on donne le matériel
informatique à des communes des petites
communes ou plutôt que de payer pour le
jeter alors que les lois ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle existe et les administrations et
son docteur fin cc
c'est impossible celui du est-ce qu
alors que c'est l'évidence
très bien merci à là on a trois
questions marché du carbone question de
l'artificialisation et l'application
prendre à d'autres questions par la
suite qui veut qui veut répondre alors
peut-être sur le marché carbone même si
je suis pas un spécialiste de l'économie
mais il est clair que demain si on veut
faire une écologie humaniste il va
falloir qu'on contractualise quelque
part l'écologie qu'on récompense les
plus vertueux
et que l'on punisse un peu ce qu'ils le
sont on s'est aperçu de ces choses-là de
la contractualisation ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne ça fonctionnait puisque vous
parler d'agriculture ça a fonctionné
parce que j'espère va pas me faire huer
dans la salle nous n'avons pas réussi
avec le glyphosate n'êtes pas sans le
savoir mais malgré tout on a
contractualisé c'est à dire que chaque
filière qui avait une solution
alternative au glyphosate et qui
pouvaient l'utiliser on l'a aidé à
l'utiliser ce qui fait qu'il ya un
certain nombre de filières aujourd'hui
qui a abandonné le glyphosate je sais
pas si on arrivera avant à éradiquer
glyphosate un jour complètement mais
c'est en contractualisant qu'on arrive à
faire les choses je vous prends peut
être un autre exemple sur l'agriculture
que vous devez bien connaître on a
entendu parler ça a été en plus déformée
par nos oppositions on dit on nous
reproche d'avoir réintroduit les
néonicotinoïdes en france c'est faux
98 6% des néonicotinoïdes sont toujours
interdits nous n'avons autorisé qu'une
chose les semences enrobées
de néonicotinoïdes pour les betteraviers
et uniquement pour les betteraviers et
uniquement en cas de suspicion de
jaunisse de la betterave ça fait quand
même beaucoup d'eux et on a autorisé sa
non pas pour les betteraviers je dis
franchement les betteraviers demain
s'ils font pas de betteraves yvan autre
chose on a autorisé ça pour sauver la
filière sucrière française qui est de
loin la meilleure d'europe
moi je préfère manger du sucre français
du sud polonais parce que je sais pas ce
qu'il ya dedans je devrais pas dire ça
mais c'est un peu vrai quand même la
différence avec ce qui s'est passé au
moment où on a voté la loi contre les
néonicotinoïdes je vais vous dire la
différence ou aller au mans la loi était
votée en 2016 il semble en 2016
l'investissement qui a été mis sur ce
problème et sur ce problème des
néonicotinoïdes et des semences enrobées
à la recherche s'étaient de 700000 euros
sept cent mille euros dès qu'on a eus
voter et à l'époque se souvient très
bien j'étais monté à la tribune en tant
que président de l' agence régionale la
biodiversité enfin les gens savaient
j'étais encore en place ce n'est pas
facile pour moi d'aller défendre sa la
gencive en auront plein la tronche sauf
que dès l'instant où cette loi était
votée à contrecoeur on aurait préféré
pouvoir faire autrement eh bien le
ministère l'agriculture débloquer 7
millions d'euros pour la recherche ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui fin 2021 on est
pratiquement déjà arriver à la solution
qui va permettre aux betteraviers de ne
plus utiliser de semences enrobées
néonicotinoïdes voilà ce que j'appelle
l'écologie de la contractualisation
alors vous avez raison sur le carbone ça
pose des problèmes les gens se posent
des questions et ça effraie un peu mais
il ya un moment où il va falloir
effectivement contractualise les choses
pour accélérer parce que malheureusement
on a beaucoup freiné ces trente
dernières années
mais quand on contractualise on tient
compte aussi ce que disait richard on
tient compte de l'humain tient compte de
l'homme de la femme ou de l'homme avec
un grand h au milieu au milieu de tout
ça pour essayer d'éviter de massacrer
des gens moi je ne supporte pas les gens
qui vous disent demain et ben tiens si
je suis élu président la république par
décret j'en tirais j'interdirais tous
les produits phytosanitaires ah ouais
ben vas-y fais-le puis après tu vas voir
si tu restes une agriculture en france
par exemple ça c'est le programme de
monsieur jadot c'est pas le nôtre nous
on va contractualiser les choses parce
que l'humain doit être au centre comme
le modem est au centre l'humain doit
être au centre de toutes les
préoccupations et ça m'empêche pas
d'être efficace
sur la question qui dépasse un peu enfin
je vais la faire un peu dépassée de la
question de l'urbanisme et du zéro
artificialisation parce que dans votre
question ce que j'entends c'est comment
on accompagne et comment on fait que les
choses soient possibles alors moi
premier point je crois qu'il faut qu'on
ait une réflexion et ça tombe bien le
président de notre mouvement politique
et et au commissaire au plan il faut
qu'on ait une vision de long terme et il
faut qu'on travaille sur un sujet un
sujet qui s'appelle la planification et
la planification écologique la
planification de la transition comment
on l'a fait dans le rapport du giec de
tout à l'heure peut-être certains se
sont peut-être été un peu plombé par le
rapport du giec mais quand vous écoutez
bien valérie masson delmotte qui qui est
qu il explique très bien on a des
possibilités
de changer et ces changements
si on les fait maintenant aux rondes et
des résultats positifs dans 20 30 ans 20
30 ans c'est quoi pour une collectivité
c'est le temps des investissements 20 30
ans une collectivité quand elles
investissent et pour 20 30 ans donc il
faut qu'on planifie et donc il faut
qu'on accompagne et ça on sait
parfaitement faire il ya plein
d'investissement comparable par exemple
dans les années dans les années 80 en
france on a fait il c'était la grande
époque du plan encore on a fait des
grands investissements dont on savait
qu'ils on note tirerait les bénéfices 20
30 ans plus tard donc ça il faut le
faire donc pour faire sable il y avait
un certain nombre de choses sur
lesquelles il faut qu'on change de
paradigme sur un certain nombre de
choses et il faut que l'écologie est
pourquoi tout à l'heure je disais
c'était de longues et de négociable ça
doit être le pivot de nos réflexions est
ce que vient de dire aussi
bruno est extrêmement intéressant et ça
m'a fait réfléchir on a beaucoup parlé
d'autres d'empathie il a parlé de la
préoccupation je crois que justement
l'écologie humaniste c'est une écologie
de l'empathie et une écologie de la
préoccupation des citoyens et c'est
comme ça qu'on en emportera les gens et
pau et pour pour conclure
il faut qu'on change un certain nombre
de choses notre constitution il ya un
certain nombre de sujets qui doivent
changer pour justement pouvoir faire
cette planification il faut par exemple
qu'on arrête de prendre les mesures
économiques écologiques dans le plf le
plan le projet de loi de finances tous
les ans tous les ans le projet de loi de
finances il ya des réglages là où
on est ça se planifie à ce moment là bas
non il faut qu'on ait une loi de
programmation de la transition comme on
a une loi de la programmation preuve de
la une loi de programmation militaire
que ensuite la finance on est sur des
bases mais qu'on aura vu avant c'est à
dire qu'on se sera donné les objectifs
et y aura eu un débat public sur ses
objectifs et ensuite je les entends là
qu'ils sont en train de râler nos
commissaires aux finances eux et que
leur boulot ça sera de faire en sorte
que on respecte ce débat public qui a eu
ce qui manque sur la transition et c'est
pour ça que ça avait un intérêt
un moment extraordinaire cette
convention citoyenne même si ça a été un
peu dur
c'était qu'ont apporté les choses on a
porté ces sujets au débat public et elle
doit ne partie cette partie on s'appelle
pas parti mouvement démocrate pour rien
il faut qu'on fasse cette articulation
entre cette ambition écologique et le
débat public pour y arriver parce que
tout le monde je vous lis c'est non
négociable il faut qu'on baisse nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
non négociable mais comment on le fait
et pour le faire il faut entraîner et
c'est pas en donnant des solutions que
en mettant les uns contre les autres
comme on entend en disant moi je suis un
écologiste radical non moi je suis un
écologiste qui va donner des solutions à
notre société et c'est ça l'écologie
humaniste et c'est ça sur lequel faut
qu'on travaille et on va le faire
ensemble
alors jimmy voulait ajouter un petit mot
oui que que les gaz à effet de serre en
fait ces trois gros tiers c'est un tiers
le transport et on a voté une loi qui
nous dit qu'on interdit d extraction
fossiles d'ici 2040 mais ça va bien plus
vite que ça en 2026 je crois je crois
pas c'est bruno qu'il dit souvent en
2026 y aura plus de véhicules hybrides
et électriques sur le marché que deux
véhicules
thermiques donc ça va très vite c'est
aussi des efforts mais ça demande des
efforts ça demande des investissements
de la part de l'acheteur sur la loi de
climat et résilience on est allé aussi
très loin dans la dans la look d'homme
dans dans dans le
dans la dans l'énergie des maisons dont
tout le monde donc comment taper la
danse dans l'art de la rénovation
énergétique on va interdire à la
location
et on va pas c'est pas simple à faire
ouais mais on va interdire allocations
les appartements les maisons qui ne
seront pas aux normes suffisante pour
baisser pour pour baisser les gaz à
effet de serre sur le transport maritime
on a une vraie révolution actuellement
tous les navires sont en train d'être
modifiée
gas gaz naturel liquéfié on développe le
transport maritime donc il ya vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites et qui demandent des contraintes
de tous l'aviation mais moyen de quelque
chose je voudrais qu'on aille un peu
plus vite sur l'aviation je ne trouve
toujours pas normal qu'on puisse
traverser l'europe pour 20 euros je
pense qu'il faut peut-être qu'on paye le
prix du billet d'avion à son juste prix
et qu'on l'acceptent
oui pour répondre sur l'administration
tu répondras aussi ce que tu connais
bien
moi je crois qu'il faut mettre dans la
lumière
voilà seule chose que j'ai vu que ça
marchait quand ce ça ça marchait pas et
administrations que ce soit sur ces
sujets là où d'autres de temps en temps
les mettre dans la lumière et leur dire
mais vous pouvez pas prendre des
décisions qui ne seront pas visibles
visible médiatiquement visible par les
citoyens et donc vous porter une
responsabilité personnelle et donc voilà
et donc vous devez être comme nous dans
la lumière de votre de vos décisions
donc je pense que ça c'est très
important et puis moi je voulais
rajouter quelque chose que j'ai oublié
tout à l'heure je pense que la politique
c'est une forme de transcendance
il ya branche idf de cette maison une
transcende une transcendance
démocrate-chrétienne may hamm donc si on
faisait même ici à calcul en levant la
main ceux qui vont à la messe demain
matin dimanche matin il y en aura un peu
et je pense que l'écologie est devenue
et pour les chefs soient demoscope
quelque chose qui nous dépasse pardon
pour moi c'est essentiel je voulais pas
ne pas vous dire ça ce qui m'anime
aujourd'hui
c'est de penser que finalement à travers
l'écologie à travers la nature certains
et notamment notre jeunesse on n'est pas
encore n'a pas réussi au modem encore
alors parler on n'a pas réussi nous
n'avons pas réussi mais nous devons
essayer est ce parce que eux ont compris
que c'est ça aujourd'hui leur nouvelle
transcendance quelque chose qui dépasse
notre propre personne quand vous êtes
élu local qu'on est député notre
fonction doit dépasser notre personne ça
veut dire que ceux qui m'habite dans ma
fonction me tire normalement ma personne
vers le haut me dépasse et des jeunes
ont compris pour eux que c'était plus
dans le politique qui vont élever
quelque chose au dessus de leur personne
mais dans l'écologie et je vous parlais
de yucca et je terminerai là-dessus
patrons du cac 20 millions de personnes
ils sont condamnés parce qu'ils me
donnent un coup de main à chaque fois
vous vous fais un truc à lucienne écrite
il ya une tête de mort et les
industriels va leur faire déposer le
bilan
en leur faisant des procès par tous au
tribunal de commerce et donc ils disent
on sait pas si c'est dangereux ou pas
mais comme ces dénigrements on va vous
condamner pour les faire déposer le
bilan et et vous allez voir ce que c'est
pour moi ces nouvelles sociétés le
patron de yucca il a trois enfants et
marié évident soit sur près de carry
droite toute façon car et les gosses
vivent dans la même chambre il a refusé
une offre à yucca pour 30% du capital
avec des clauses pourtant pas trop
pourri à 100 millions d'euros
j'ai passé tellement d'heures avec lui
que je ne croyais pas ce type je lisais
mais c'est du pipeau il ya un moment
donné il ya un loup quelque part vous
avez des jeunes qui pensent que c'est
peut-être dans l'entreprise on voit dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans
l'entreprise citoyenne et qui cherche
cette nouvelle transcendance moi je
crois en la politique et donc je pense
qu'à travers cette écologie là on doit
le leur offrir et nous offrir à nous
mêmes quelque chose qui le dépasse sinon
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose qui n'est
pas cet homme et la femme n'y a pas
d'humanité
moi simplement je voulais répondre à
monsieur qui est donc élu et avec le
sujet de l'accompagnement et par rapport
à l'artificialisation
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a une
question fondamentale à se poser c'est
le devenir de la loi sru alors on ne
sait pas ce soir qu'on va en parler mais
c'est vrai que c'est un vrai sujet
puisque aussi on a une fiscalité locale
qui favorise plutôt la création de
foncier l'étalement urbain donc ça va en
contradiction est ce qu'on veut mettre
en place et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on le voit sur les territoires quand on
rencontre les maires dans nos tous les
territoires ça construit il ya une
pression qui est fait qui est demandé
par par le gouvernement et moi je n'y
suis pas favorable parce qu'à un moment
donné ça déséquilibre et on accueille
des populations qui viennent vers nous
parce que c'est moins cher parce que on
peut avoir une maison à 100 m² avec un
petit jardin parce que nous on est en
grande couronne et pour autant ça me
permet ça déséquilibre la ville sur
beaucoup de domaines et je crois que
l'ia la nécessaire accompagnement pour
les collectivités territoriales pour
autant je crois qu'il faudra qu'on
réfléchisse réellement à la loi sru et
qu'on arrête de construire à tout crin
alors on va prendre deux petites
questions
pour terminer
rapide alors il y avait monsieur et
madame
en tout cas
merci erwan
donner de l'information et la parole aux
finances
il faut savoir alors c'est une
information peut être pour certains que
notre pays a pour la première fois la
commission de finances si on l'a voté
ensuite en assemblée pour ceux qui
étaient là le budget vers un budget vert
c'est la première fois qu'on analyse
c'est près de 580 4 704 5 74 milliards
au travers justement de l'impact sur
l'environnement
donc je vous invite tous bien évidemment
à dire ça c'est c'est la première fois
et c'est notre pays qui le fait dans le
monde le seul
analyser avec un budget vert avec six
objectifs et on va analyser pour chacun
des objectifs quel impact positif au
négatif sur notre environnement et les
six objectifs vous le rappelle
rapidement lutte contre le changement
climatique l'adaptation au changement
climatique et la prévention des risques
naturels la gestion de la ressource en
eau l'économie circulaire les déchets
prévention des risques technologiques
la lutte contre les pollutions et la
biodiversité
donc juge pour information c'est un
budget r
c'est alors commission des finances qui
a été discutée et votée voilà donc quand
on dit que les finances c'est à côté non
la finance est partout
merci merci alors juste une dernière
question et tu pourras répondre après en
concurrents
voilà je suis médecin j'étais ya très
longtemps et j'ai découvert un mouvement
qui me plaît le modem le modem alors je
lis écologie humaniste et je trouve ce
titre très bien ce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est que est ce que cette écologie peut
aussi aller en afrique c'est à dire que
pour faire est ce qu'on peut faire payer
les entreprises qui polluent en afrique
parce qu'ils font les composantes de la
porte des portables et des voitures
électriques qui polluent les rivières en
afrique est ce qu'on peut faire quelque
chose pour cela parce que l'écologie ce
n'est pas qu'à deux robes c'est toute la
terre merci merci beaucoup
non justin mohamed est arrivé tu es
arrivé en cours je suis désolé la
question c'est pas du tout dans le
budget vert c'est un super un super truc
qu'on a inventé on est le pays est l'un
des premiers pays à le faire à ce niveau
là moi ce que je te dit tout simplement
c'est que on ne fera la transition que
si on a une planification et cette
planification et doit passer par un
débat public qui sera non pas sur des
amendements en loi de finances qui sont
qui arriveront de toute façon parce que
c'est votre boulot et vous le faites
super bien mais qui est un engagement de
la société et qu'on a une vision de là
où on veut aller c'est tout c'est tout
c'est tout simplement ça et le le budget
vert ça va exactement dans le sens de ce
que je prône mois sur l'évaluation
climatique des lois c'est à dire que de
la même façon qu'on évalue les dépenses
publiques dans ce pays on évalue nos
dépenses ou nos économies carbone c'est
à dire que quand décide de faire une loi
on regarde quel impact elle a sur le
climat et que si elle ne respecte pas
les engagements que nous avons pris au
niveau international et ça fera la
transition sur les questions de
l'afrique et sur les questions de notre
rôle est de notre responsabilité
eh ben on peut pas elles ne peuvent pas
exister des décisions ne pourraient pas
exister tout simplement parce qu'elle ne
serait pas dans les critères que nous
nous sommes fixés au moment des accords
de paris et que nous allons réviser au
prochain à la prochaine cup qui est la
coop 26 oui alors madame merci pour
votre question concernant l'afrique je
suis également membre comme certains
autres de mes collègues je vois pas
bonnafous cnam et de la de l'assemblée
des parlementaires francophones
donc on a des actions effectivement
aussi en afrique moi je m'occupe du
réseau
sida
sida tuberculose et paludisme et on a
commencé à faire quelque chose dans les
fonds dead est bien évidemment il faut
il faut éviter autant que faire se peut
que se reproduisent dans les pays en
voie de développement ou émergents
qu'ils reproduisent les erreurs que nous
on a commis il y a quelques années et un
certain nombre d'années donc il ya aussi
beaucoup de contractualisation
maintenant dans les aides qu'on donne si
je prends l'exemple pour le sida par
exemple
parce que tuberculose et paludisme
l'afrique est moins touché que par le
sida il ya eu un coup il n'y a pas eu de
coup d'arrêt parce que le fond dette
continue à être être là et on continue à
donner l'argent pour combattre ce fléau
mais on a mis quand même des warnings à
l'ensemble des pays de l'afrique de
l'ouest à l'ensemble des pays de
l'afrique pour leur dire attention on
constate que sur les fonts dette que
vous recevez tout ne va pas tout ne va
pas dans la défense et dans
l'éradication
du vih
donc c'est comme ça qu'on peut agir
aussi on peut aussi essayer d'agir avec
nos entreprises qui elles vont sur le
territoire d'afrique et pour certaines
gagnent beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup
d'argent souvent sur le dos des
africains on est bien d'accord là dessus
de d'être beaucoup plus vigeant ce que
disait ce que disait avant tout à
l'heure dans ce type aussi de
contractualisation de contractualisation
qu'on peut passer avec les états
africains avec les gouvernements des
différents pays africains ne le sais tu
pas ne pas aider au développement des
pays d'afrique mais c'est de pas être
naïf et d'imposer des règles
de part et d'autre qui doivent être
respectées sinon on ira pas plus loin je
sais c'est pas c'est pas être
dictatorial ou méchant il faut
simplement qu'ils soient respectés de
part et d'autre est à cette condition là
on y arrivera mais beaucoup de pays
d'afrique ont déjà pris conscience que
l'écologie est vraiment un problème et
refusent déjà des pratiques qui ne sont
pas vertueuse donc le ya bon espoir là
dessus
merci beaucoup merci à tous l'écologie
humaniste l'écologie qui est pour tous
bravo à nos à nos députés je vous
propose pour conclure une vidéo de
pascal canfin qui est président de la
commission développement durable au
parlement européen et après cette vidéo
vous serez tous invités à aller dîner
merci beaucoup on regarde la vidéo qui
va arriver
bonjour je vous remercie pour votre
invitation malheureusement je ne peux
pas être parmi vous physiquement
aujourd'hui mais c'est avec grand
plaisir que je partage ce message merci
de votre côté me permettre de le faire
on est évidemment à un moment tout à
fait particulier où on peut commencer à
tirer un bilan de l'action du
gouvernement depuis un peu plus de
quatre ans sur l'environnement et en
même temps on doit et on va commencer à
se projeter sur la suite à un moment où
en europe les choses battent leur plein
dans ce qu'on appelle le green deal qui
est la nouvelle donne européenne sur ces
sujets alors premiers éléments de
partager quel bilan on peut faire de
l'action du gouvernement français sur
les enjeux environnementaux et
climatiques
lorsque l'on des zooms un tout petit peu
et que l'on regarde les comparaisons
internationales
la plupart de temps voire même toujours
la france se situe dans les meilleurs
élèves alors je peux prendre le
classement des plans de relance au
regard de leur degré de verdissement et
de leur contribution à la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique à la france
est classée parmi les meilleures au
monde et le plan européen qui doit
beaucoup à la france on le sait à
l'action du président de la république
et lui même aussi classé comme le
deuxième
ailleurs au monde après celui de la
corée du sud si on prend l'action de
manière transversale est évalué par les
ong européennes ce qu'on appelle le
climate action network donc le réseau
action climat européen ici à bruxelles
de là où j'enregistre la vidéo et bien
nous sommes en france les troisièmes en
europe en termes d'actions favorable à
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique
derrière la suède et le portugal si je
prends d'autres exemples très précis
comme l'aviation et la fameuse
proposition la convention citoyenne de
dire jusqu'à une certaine limite
eh bien j'ai interdit les vols
court-courriers et je bascule sur
l'avion mais on est les seuls en europe
avec l'autriche à mettre en place ce
type de dispositif je pourrais
multiplier les comparaisons je n'ai pas
le temps de le faire simplement pour
vous dire qu'on n'a pas à rougir de ce
qui a été fait mais je le dis aussi
aussi clairement que le fait qu'on n'ait
pas à rougir de ce qui a été fait il va
falloir en faire plus il va falloir en
faire plus on le sait tous parce que
nous ne sommes pas en train de gagner la
bataille pour le climat et le
réchauffement climatique malheureusement
continue des derniers rapports du giec
l'ont encore démontré mais possible
parce que l'accord européen que nous
avons trouvés notamment grâce au soutien
de la france exige de nous que nous
fassions plus dans les années qui
viennent je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail technique mais sachez que en
europe nous sommes en train de changer
plus de cinquante loi 50 loi en même
temps quand je dis en même temps c'est
entre 2020 et 2022 donc en deux ans 50
loi sur à peu près tous les sujets la
finance le prix du carbone le commerce
l'agriculture etc et quand on change 50
loin en même temps on est bien placé
pour savoir nous responsables politiques
que ça devient un changement systémique
et ce changement systémique bien
évidemment il aura des répercussions
majeures sur des acteurs économiques
français je prendre un seul exemple qui
parlera à tout le monde les voitures
nous avons aujourd'hui une date de fin
des v hull thermique donc de la
commercialisation des nouvelles voitures
essence diesel tout ça s'arrête en 2035
dans 13 14 ans et sera remplacé par 100
% de véhicules zéro émission ça veut
dire qu'en 13 ans nous allons en europe
et donc en france transformer totalement
la plus grande industrie européenne en
termes d'emplois et ça aura des impacts
sur tous nos territoires et c'est pour
ça que le coeur me semble-t-il de notre
analyse au niveau du projet présidentiel
futur doit porter sur la méthode parce
que le qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on le
sait est non seulement on le fait déjà
ou alors c est en train d'être négocié
au niveau européen la question
fondamentale c'est le comment le comment
parce qu on est bien placé en france
pour savoir que lorsque l'on prend la
mauvaise voie bien ça bloque on l'a fait
avec les bonnets rouges on l'a fait avec
les gilet jaune et si on reprend demain
une mauvaise voie on aura de nouveau ce
type de problème et donc la question de
la méthode est fondamental parce que le
coeur du sujet c'est de transformer en
profondeur sans fracture est la société
et si je dois conclure avec une seule
idée il en aurait évidemment beaucoup
qui mériterait d'être partagée
maintenant mais une seule idée c'est que
le moment politique moment historique
dans lequel nous sommes c'est que nous
devons négocier les transition
écologique et l'image que je peux
prendre c'est celle de l'état providence
au 20e siècle au fond on doit faire au
21e siècle ce qu'on a fait au xxème
siècle pour l'état providence ta
providence on a mis plusieurs décennies
à le négocier c'est un mélange de règles
de normatif et de négociation en
l'occurrence entre partenaires sociaux
sur différents sujets les retraites
assurance maladie sur le chômage etc etc
et ça appartient à tout le monde cet
état providence part c'est un peu les
gaullistes un peu les communistes un peu
les démocrates-chrétiens un peu la
social démocratie mais la transition
écologique ce sera la même chose pour
que ça change d'échelle et qu'on invente
en trente ans le modèle zéro carbone
c'est ça l'objectif européen l'anneau
réalité carbone en 2050 eh bien il faut
tout le monde s'y met et que tout le
monde apporte sa pierre à l'édifice dans
le cas d'une négociation de négociation
avec un s parce qu'il ya tellement
d'objets qu'il n'y en aura bien
évidemment plusieurs or nous sommes très
peu outillés aujourd'hui pour le faire
on sait faire des négociations de
partenaires sociaux on sait pas faire
encore des négociations de la transition
écologique que l'on pense aux différents
enjeux énergétiques agricoles de
transport dans les différents
territoires etc et c'est là je pense où
vous avez un rôle fondamental à jouer en
tant que famille politique dans la
majorité avec aussi son histoire
spécifique et ce à son approche
spécifique parce que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui vous tient
particulièrement à coeur et dans cette
négociation un des enjeux clés c'est
évidemment de trouver les modèles
économiques les modèles économiques qui
permettent de déployer les solutions
technologiques à grande échelle et c ont
parfois on l'a véhicules électriques par
exemple est un cas positif parfois on ne
l'a pas encore essayé de cette
négociation qui permet de faire émerger
ces modèles économiques qui transforme
dans la durée et qui emporte la société
qui emporte les entreprises sans
fractures et des sans perdre en
compétitivité voilà la feuille de route
que je pense valable de nous fixer pour
les prochains mois et puis ensuite les
prochaines années si les choses se
passent bien d'un point de vue
démocratique en tout cas sachez que en
europe c'est exactement ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et je sais que
vous y êtes particulièrement attachée au
sein de la délégation renaissance de
nombreux représentantes et représentants
du modem y contribue activement je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté